gonna get into it yeah but i've i've had  rumor spread about me and then you just  carried on to college and stuff like we  do that type of job i don't think it  would be like anything serious like  anything that you could take legal  action upon like oh this guy like it's  kind of like university oh this like  it's a small university that we have in  new york right and if someone has sex  with someone it's instant because it's  just a small campus so like the rumor  the word gets around quickly but i just  like i don't think they they should be  like legally but i think it does exactly  exactly you know what i mean if it takes  away opportunities from you and biggest  opportunities then  you should